we never stopped hearing about how the
Internet's in the cloud but really it's
in the ocean about 300 undersea
fiber-optic cables are responsible for
99% of international data traffic it's
basically the same way we connect to
each other in a single country except
underwater instead of underground they
transmit PewDiePie from Europe to
America and they connect stock traders
in New York and London in these cables
placed by private companies a backbone
of the internet but if you held one in
your hand it would be no bigger than a
soda can there are just a few layers of
protection from the water including
petroleum jelly yes your internet is
covered in Vaseline they're vulnerable
to earthquakes at least a few times
confuse sharks have bitten them but many
cables are beneath sea life because in
some places they go as deep underwater
as Mount Everest is high ships lower a
plow that digs a tiny groove in the
ocean floor lay in the cable and it's
naturally buried by saying thanks to the
oceans current and that process it's
both stunningly simple and mind-blowing
ly complex is responsible for making the
internet a truly global network it's an
idea that's audacious and crazy and you
think it has to be cutting-edge and it
is but it's also been going on for a
hundred fifty seven years electric
Telegraph's have been around for a long
long time experiments in the early
eighteen hundreds connected two ends of
a garden using a clock that revealed
letters then they moved on to to
neighborhoods help signal trains and
then multiple cities thanks to a network
of railroad lines underwater submarine
cables were an obvious next step so they
played around instead of petroleum jelly
the first ones were coated with exotic
tree sap to protect them from the water
and though the undersea cables came in
spurts one of the first ones was knocked
out of commission by a fishing boat by
1858 they reached around the Atlantic
and across the world and that's how its
kind of gone since laying cables that
circle the Earth's oceans
the cables are unwound from the back of
the [ __ ] sink to the ocean floor and the
world is connected in speeds measured in
milliseconds there are ideas to bring
the Internet above sea level along with
cellphone towers there's internet beamed
from Facebook satellites to Africa
balloons lifted by Google but for speedy
international travel undersea cables or
still where companies like Facebook and
Google place their bets that's because
the best way to create the cloud is
still by going under the sea
[Music]
you
[Music]